Arne Roomann-Kurrik:
We're gonna talk about ways
that you can optimize
your existing OpenSocial app
in the context of
a high traffic application.
If you have any questions
during the session,
we'll take questions
afterwards,
if we have
a little bit of extra time.
There's a link here
to go to Google Moderator
where you
can add a question,
and if we can get to them
then we'll answer them.
So to begin, let's talk
about what success means
as a social application
developer.
Obviously,
the more money you make
the better you're doing.
So the trouble with
this is that social eCPM
is basically, like...
is very low compared
to the rest of
the web-type industries.
It's actually the lowest of
news, entertainment,
technology, gaming.
So basically,
for each page render
of your social application,
you're making less money
than other industries.
The good thing
about this, though,
is that you have direct access
to millions of signed in users.
Usually if
your application's running
inside of a social platform,
those users have
a very low barrier to entry
to install your application.
And there's
also growth functionality
built into a lot of platforms.
So you can share your app,
invite your friends, et cetera.
And so, social applications
see a lot of growth,
and a lot of
very quick growth.
So, um, even though
that the CPM is pretty low,
you have growth
to make up for it.
Now what this means in terms
of performance, though,
is that small tweaks
really matter.
And let's look
at a few quotes about
how small tweaks
really do matter
for large-scale
applications.
Here's a quote
from Marissa Mayer,
talking about how
when Google was deciding
on how many results to return
in their search index.
They actually did experiments
with different types of users
to determine what
was the optimal number.
And by increasing
the number of results,
they actually
slowed down rendering time
by about half a second.
Now the group that actually
had the--more results
wound up dropping off their
traffic by about 20%.
That means about
20% fewer Google searches
happened because
the page was slow.
So if half a second of latency
makes that much difference,
then you can see how important
it is to a big site like Google.
Here's a quote from
Greg Linden at Amazon,
talking about how Amazon
also did experiments
with latency to see
how it would affect sales.
When they increased
the page load by 0.1 seconds--
that's 100 milliseconds--
it cost them
1% of their sales.
There's, like,
a direct correlation
between latency
and the amount of sales
that Amazon
was experiencing.
Finally, last quote by Marissa
is talking
about how Google Maps,
after they first launched,
had a 100KB page load.
Uh, now they have had
a lot of adoption quickly,
but then they decided
that there was actually
ways that they
could optimize their size.
And they actually trimmed
about 30KB of JavaScript
out of the initial download.
Now dropping the 30KB,
actually, from that point on
made Google Maps
grow by 30% in three weeks.
So there
was actually, again,
a direct correlation
between page size
and the amount of growth
they experienced.
So for this presentation,
we're going to measure
the impact of changes
on large scale applications.
So they're sort
of applications that once
you actually make it,
like, reasonably large
in the OpenSocial space,
these are the tweaks
that will actually help you
lower your costs and
then make your users happier.
To do this,
we actually wrote
a sample
OpenSocial application.
And we rewrote it,
like, four times.
And what that was
was each time we rewrote it,
we isolated different strategies
to optimize the application.
And then we
did metrics to count it
and see what
the net effect was.
The idea is
that we can show you--
We can show you ways
that you can deliver
a fast user experience.
We can
also minimize the costs,
so reducing the amount of server
charges that you need to spend.
And then highlight
some new OpenSocial features
that you
might not be aware of
that you can
use in your apps today.
Or, uh, yeah.
So the app that we wrote
was called "Quartermile".
Basically, it's very, uh--
Oh, sorry.
Uh, it's...I'm sorry.
[chuckles]
Here we go.
Uh, here's a live--
live demo of how the app works.
I'm actually in Orkut
right now
and I'm installing it
into the UI.
Accepting ad application.
You can see that--
the interface is
that it's
a fitness application.
And what it does
is when you first load it,
it asks you what team
you'd like to be on.
So here, I'm just
gonna pick one of the teams
that my friends are
members of.
And you can see, there's
actually team data coming in
upon the load of the app.
So on the middle column,
you can see
the graphs about
what the fitness was.
On the right, there's
individual fitness activities.
What I'm doing
right now is I'm sending
an invite
to one of my friends
Just to invite them
to my team.
So I joined a team,
and then now
I'm getting one of
my friends to join me also.
Now I'm gonna start entering
in some fitness data.
So here I'm just typing it
in natural English--
"I walked one mile yesterday."
And I'm posting this activity.
And when I post it,
the graphs update.
And you can see
that there's now three people
actively contributing
to this team.
On the right hand side, there's
actually a list of activities.
And my activity is
marked with
the number of foodles
that activity is worth.
So we kind of came up
with some metrics
on, you know, running
is worth "X" number of foodles
if you do it for so long,
and whatever.
And we kind of standardize
all our exercises together.
So in this case,
I'm typing in
that I ran two miles
two days ago.
And you can see
that the graph updates.
Here, I'm doing
1,000 sit-ups on May 23rd.
And the graph updates also.
So there's different types
of exercises,
kind of standardized
into one general data set.
And this will
kind of just show you--
this is the sort
of social application,
you know, exercising
with your friends,
that you would see
in a real ecosystem.
I guess there's potential,
or maybe to flatter myself,
there's potential
for it to grow pretty large.
Uh, the backend is built
on Google App Engine.
Basically, we structured
it so that
the backend was called
via JSON RPC calls.
Transferring data back
and forth from the frontends.
The frontends were written
in many different ways,
so actually if you were
at the previous session,
"Google and the Social Web,"
you saw a few
of those frontends running
in different containers.
The one that we wrote for this
was a little bit different
because we kept the same
functionality,
and we just rewrote it to see
how we could optimize that.
There's a few links here
on the slides.
Feel free
to check them out later.
All this stuff
will be posted online.
And to measure it, we have three
different types of requests:
basically, API requests
to the backend--
the App Engine backend.
We have API requests
to the OpenSocial APIs
on the container
in which it runs.
And then we have assets,
like JavaScript,
CSS images, et cetera.
And we're measuring on
four different metric points.
Bandwidth per page view--
so the total download size
that the server is serving up
every time the page is loaded.
The number of
requests per page view.
That's just counting the number
of individual HTTP requests,
The latency per page view--
so the amount of time
that it takes from the time
that the app is loaded
until it's ready to use.
And then CPU time is actually
a metric unique to App Engine.
But what it is,
is basically how--
a measure of how much
backend work we're doing.
The reason
we're actually including this
in the measurements
is we can actually
do a cost calculation
on this later on.
Now measuring each of these
individually is important
because you can actually
sometimes tweak one
while you're
not affecting the others.
And you have certain amounts of
control over certain requests,
and you don't really
over others.
So being able to realize
what you can optimize
and what you
can't optimize is important.
So here are the raw numbers
for the "Naive" Implementation.
And what we did was
we wrote this application
as if you had just read
the OpenSocial tutorial
for the first time.
And you just started
writing this app,
and you kind of
threw everything in there
and got it together.
You can see that
we broke it down again
through API calls
to the Quartermile backend,
through social
requests to OpenSocial,
and then image and CSS
in JavaScript.
And then finally,
the only metric which actually
has a server
processing metric
is API calls to
the Quartermile backend.
'Cause the rest of it is
pretty much free for our server.
Now when you
actually look at the raw--
the first set of metrics
that we counted was,
first of all,
the latency of the gadget.
And we'll cover
more about this later,
but this is basically
the gadget perceived latency.
From the time that
the head of the gadget renders
to the time that it's
first usable by the end user,
it took us about 2.7 seconds.
The next latency metric
is the page latency.
So if you were
to just open up the iFrame
in which this gadget ran,
and then reload it
and measured that speed,
that was about 3.5 seconds.
Now, this is maybe
a little bit more accurate
in terms of perceived latency,
just because
it's the amount of time
that the user sees,
not what the gadget sees.
So it includes the round-trips
to our backend server.
Finally,
the number of requests--
it took
26 HTTP requests
to render the gadget
for the first time,
including images, CSS,
backend API calls, et cetera.
And then we just
ran it through YSlow
which we'll
talk about more later.
But we got
a not so great score of 72.
Finally,
the cost of this app...
Just doing some numbers
and really thinking about
like, how can we
put this in perspective
to you as an app developer?
Is--if you have a reasonable
amount of traffic--
And reasonable
is actually fairly large
by most web standards,
but for a social application
is not really that huge--
is at 11 QPS on average.
Winds up being about
a million page views a day,
30 million over
the course of a month.
And when we
actually did all that,
then we found out
the app consumes about
5 terabytes
of bandwidth traffic,
and 1,859 hours of CPUs.
Now, the great thing
about these two measurements
is that App Engine actually
has set costs for these.
So we can kind of estimate
what it would cost
to add this amount of traffic
onto our existing app engine.
Now keep in mind that this isn't
really a direct correlation
of what you would pay to run
this app on App Engine,
because App Engine
does have a free quota.
And this is really just saying
if you had a million extra
page views a day,
you would be paying
about $900 a month more
for that amount of traffic.
It's certainly reasonable
for apps to scale that large.
We have social apps going up to,
you know, the hundreds of QPS.
So 11 isn't really--
isn't really that strange.
Chris Chabot:
So when we're looking...
[inaudible]
...important to keep
in mind that
gadgets are actually
web pages as well.
They're a web page
embedded in an iFrame
within a social profile.
So any of the optimizations
that we know to do to web pages
count for gadgets as well.
So some of the tricks
that we'll be looking at
is how to reduce
the size of the page,
how to reduce
the amount of requests
that a page needs to make
to actually
make the gadget work
and render
and be displayed,
and we'll be looking
at the total latency
that a gadget
has associated with it
before you can start
interacting with it.
To look at all
these different numbers
and to be able to investigate
how your application is doing,
there's a number
of tools for pretty much
every mainstream web browser.
If you're using Safari,
then the Web Inspector's
the awesome tool to use.
If you're using Firefox,
then you've got Firebug and
YSlow to analyze your results.
And in IE, you've
got tools like HttpWatch
with which you can
analyze what's happening.
So one of
the first big tricks
that you have
with web development
to make your application slower
is by concatenating
all your JavaScript files
into one big file,
concatenating all your CSS files
into one big file too.
That way you only have
to download one big file
instead of making several
requests to your backend server.
Making a request to a server
over HTTP is really slow
because you're making
a TCP/IP connection,
you're talking protocol
with a server.
So just by removing that
from downloading the app
it already
becomes a lot faster.
So you're using
a bit less bandwidth,
your latency is going down,
and the amount of requests
that you're making
is going down.
Then the next step is
to compress those things.
There's a number
of tools for that,
like JSMin, YUI Compressor,
et cetera.
And you can use that
to compress your JavaScripts.
What it will do is it will
take your JavaScript,
as you see here,
and it will remove everything
that's not
"syntaxually" required.
So spaces, line breaks--
It will even go so far
sometimes as to rename variables
to shorten names just
to save size.
You can see the results
that you're getting
using those tools
in your browsers.
Like, here's
a little example of what
it would look like
in Safari,
and you see
a total download size.
So when we did this
to Quartermile
we noticed that we saved up
to 54% of the download size
on this JavaScript
in the stylesheet assets.
So that's a huge reduction
in the amount of
bandwidth required,
and you sped up your application
by quite a bit as well,
resulting in a saving, well,
on this monthly amount of $61.
So that's pretty damn good.
The next thing you
want to look at is latency.
When you're developing
your application you'll be
working on your own server,
and you can use tools--
again, like the
Web Inspector and Firebug--
to see what the total loading
time of your application is.
And that's a great trick, and
it's a great way to make sure
that you're optimizing it
as much as possible.
But at some point,
you get into the situation
where your app is deployed
on a social networking site.
And there's gonna
be people using it,
and they're not gonna be
in the same ISB as you.
They're not gonna be
in the same country as you.
They might be
going through proxy servers,
different network routes,
et cetera.
So how do you measure that?
And how do you figure out
where in the world
your people are coming from
and what their experience
of the application is?
So we know we need to measure
this from different locations.
We know that we need
to keep measuring it as well,
because situations change.
Your application can
suddenly become really popular,
or maybe you gain a
lot of users in a country
where you didn't expect
you would get a lot of users.
And you might
want to invest in a city,
and/or bringing a server
closer to those users
so they get
a really fast experience too.
So to be able to measure that
you can't use
those standard tools anymore
and you need to build something
yourself, some custom code.
And here's an example of how
you would do this in JavaScript.
For instance,
for measuring the latency,
you could
create an image element,
then you add
an onload function to it,
and that forces
the web browser to actually
always download that image.
And then on the onload event,
you measure,
"Hey, I started at this time,
and I ended at this time.
So I know what my
network latency is now."
This is great for
defining the network latency.
Then there's also the latency
for, "How long does it take
to make an API call
to my own backend server?"
So you would put
the same type of code
around the data calls
to your server as well.
And you can combine
those graphs saying,
"Well, here I see that my
network latency is really low,
"but the latency for making
data calls is really high.
"So now I know that
my servers are slowing down,
"and I need to invest
in that to make sure that
the latency keeps low and
my users keep on being happy."
The next trick
that you can use
from web development
is image spriting.
Image spriting
is a technology where
you take a number of images
and you combine it
into one big image file.
And you use stylesheets
to position that as a background
in the element to
only show the bit of the image
that you're interested
in displaying in that part.
The big benefit to doing this
is that you reduce
the amount of requests
you're making to your server
by quite a bit again.
You only have to download
one image file
instead of having to download
10 or 20 of them.
So the latency goes down,
total request count goes down,
and you can use tools like--
Well, YSlow
is one of my favorites
because it shows
you both the situation
when you have
a completely clean browser
that's never
been to this page before,
and it shows you when
you've gone there before
and you've got a primed cache.
So everything that's cacheable
is already in your cache.
And it will show you
a beautiful breakdown
of the amount
of requests you're making,
what kind of a request count is
going to what type of resource.
So when we applied
this image spriting technique
to Quartermile,
we noticed that latency
went down
by quite a bit--45%.
And that's a really good save.
However, we also noticed
that the size was going up,
because there's
always a little bit
of white space
in your bigger image.
So the next thing we did
is that we optimized
the palette of
the image file as well.
So you're reducing
the palette size,
means there's less
being stored.
And we ended up actually
saving quite a bit
on the size of it as well.
And we went from 15
image requests to just 1,
which is a big save indeed.
So the saving
in the amount of dollars
that you're doing here
isn't that big.
The biggest saving is probably
that your application
is gonna be a lot faster,
which means that you're
gonna get happier users
that are coming back
more often
and using the application
more often as well.
The last thing that
I want to cover in this bit
about general web optimization
is caching headers.
It's one of
the really nifty tricks.
That's--your web browser
has seen this image before.
It knows that it's still
valid--it's local copy--
so it doesn't even
have to download.
It doesn't have
to connect to your server.
It can just
instantly display it
without having
to do any actions.
So it's the ultimate
optimization trick.
The downside is that
not everybody's using this yet.
So when you're
using dynamic languages,
you can use whatever
language you're using
to set a header
with a cache control max age
as some really high number
into the future
to tell the web browser,
"Hey, you can save this file.
You don't have to
re-download it every time."
For static files, you can
configure your web server
to say, well, "Hey, whenever
you find a file of this type,
"just append the caching
header to it so that
the browser will know
it can cache that as well."
And here's a little example
of how you would configure
that in Apache,
where we tell it, well,
anything that matches
against the stylesheet--
a JavaScript, a GIF file,
a JPEG, or a BMG--
just append this
cache control header to it,
and you can cache it for about
two years into the future.
Now one of the things
that you might be worried about
is, so if I change my CSS file,
my JavaScript file,
howdo I tell the browser
to download it again?
That's what we're using
cache-busting techniques for.
And that's
basically appending, like,
a version is some number
after the query screen.
And the browser will
know, like,
"Hey, this is
a different year row,"
and download it again, and then
cache it again for two years.
Roomann-Kurrik:
The next section that I'd like
to talk about is beyond
normal web optimizations.
What are the optimizations
that you can do
because you're actually
running on a social network?
So things that
the network servers
are actually
gonna help you out with.
Um, there's certainly
a good reason
why they would
want to help you out--
is because if
you have a social gadget
and a small tweak
will make a significant
impact on your revenue--
If you're a social network
you've got the aggregate benefit
of all of those tweaks,
so if you can force
some of them to happen
then obviously it's in their
best interests even more so.
Some of the advantages
that a social network has
that you don't really have
is that they can control
what HTML they output.
So even though
you're writing a gadget spec
in an XML file and et cetera,
eventually that
gets rendered into HTML
and gets put out
by the social network.
So they can really control
what content they deliver.
And then second of all,
is that social networks
usually will have better
infrastructure than your app.
You know, they probably
have servers around the globe
that they can use
to optimize requests
and pages that
are served to their users.
So along that line,
OpenSocial offers a feature
called a Static Content Proxy.
The idea is that
a social network is willing
to absorb some
traffic for you, right?
They're actually willing to host
some files on your behalf.
And there's nothing you
really need to do to sign up
or use this, except rewrite
one of--some of your URLs
to take advantage of
this service.
Some social networks host
these files on CDNs,
which are
Content Delivery Networks.
Basically, it's a
set of distributed servers
that are
very heavily optimized
for delivering static images
and assets to your end users.
So first of all,
these servers are very close
to your end users.
And then when
the user requests an image,
or a flash file,
or whatever,
it actually goes to
a server that's closest to it
and then the latency
is much quicker.
This is really important when
your home servers are,
like, centrally located.
So for example, if you're
running a server
here in San Francisco,
and you have
a lot of users
in Brazil and India,
instead of coming all the way
to your server to get data,
they can actually go to a CDN
or whatever in India,
and the experience is
vastly improved
for most of those users.
And the simple call
to do this inside of a gadget
is to call
"gadgets.io.getProxyUrl."
And that will just basically
take whatever URL you give it
and put it on
this Static Content host.
Naturally, you want
to keep in mind, though,
that anything
that's hosted on this way
is not gonna touch
your server or anything.
So it'll be hit
the first time it's requested,
but then after that
it'll probably
effectively be cached
for a long time.
So only put
stuff that really can--
doesn't need to be dynamically
modified on each page render.
Uh, secondly,
the social network controls
what HTML it outputs
to the browser.
So that means
that even though you say
that there needs
to be an image file here
and a JavaScript file there
and CSS there,
they can actually
make some optimizations
that will improve
the speed of your gadget
without you even really
needing to be aware
of certain optimizations.
For example,
one thing that they'll do
is concatenate
JavaScript files.
So--like Chris mentioned.
Another thing that they'll do
is run minification programs
on the concatenated result.
And then a third thing
they'll do is, you know,
rearrange elements
in the page to make them
more optimal for the browser.
So things like putting
CSS at the top of the page
so that the browser
gets it first
and doesn't have to re-render
after it gets additional CSS.
Or putting JavaScript
at the end of the page,
so that it executes
after all the DOM is loaded.
And it just delivers
a better experience, sorry.
Naturally, this leads
to a little bit of confusion
for app developers who
all of a sudden find themselves
on a container that's doing
these kinds of optimizations.
So say there's an image
that needs to be different
every time the page
is loaded or something.
You can actually opt-out
of having
certain URLs and tags
be rewritten.
And this little snippet here
just kind of shows
how you can declaratively
adjust this rewriting.
You have the option to include
URLs that need to be rewritten.
You can have
the option to exclude URLs.
And it'll take a glob pattern,
so you can just kind of
define a pattern that should
be rewritten or should not be.
Keeping in the vein
of things that you can do
as an OpenSocial
application developer
that you can't do
as a website developer,
there's
a whole bunch of features
that OpenSocial
kind of gives you.
And the reason
it gives you these
is certain optimizations
only make sense
when you're
running a social app.
And so when the OpenSocial
spec was created,
a lot of conveniences
and functionality
was put in just
with the thought that
"Hey, we're gonna
have a lot of users
"running apps that have
millions and millions
"of users accessing them.
So we'll make it easier
for developers at that scale."
One thing that
I'd like to point out
is that when you
examine the OpenSocial API,
a lot of it seems
like it's a little bit
possibly confusing,
or whatever.
But a lot of the decisions were
made for the scaling reasons.
And so when you're
designing your own APIs,
like we did with Quartermile,
we actually took
advantage of some of these
and kind of mimicked
what was going on.
For example, we
took advantage of batching.
So the idea is that you
want to minimize HTTP requests.
So whenever you're
doing a social call,
if you do it incorrectly,
then it'll be
causing one HTTP request
each time
you make the call.
So the first example here
is actually four lines of code
that sends four HTTP requests.
That's not optimal at all.
It's actually--there's
a whole lot of reasons
why this would be bad.
But basically, what you
can do to alleviate this
is do as much as you can
in a single trip.
So you make a batch operation,
and you add requests to it,
and then you execute the batch.
And then that
sends all of the requests
together in one payload.
The server processes it
all at once on it's backend
and then sends you back all of
the responses at the same time.
You're only really waiting
for one request to process.
And using this approach,
we actually designed
the Quartermile API to take
advantage of batching, too.
So where we were making
two OpenSocial requests,
we made one.
And then when we made four
Quartermile API requests,
we made one request also.
This had the net effect
that you'll see here.
It's actually
kind of interesting,
because we didn't really see
what we were expecting to see
when we made these
batching optimizations.
One thing was latency
actually on average
did increase very slightly--
like, by 13 milliseconds--
which is certainly not
perceptible to the end user,
but it's also not the greatest
benefit that we were expecting.
And possibly part of
the reason we saw this
was because we were testing
too close to our own servers.
So, you know, it didn't really
make that much of a difference.
Now, if you're actually
located in a position
where making
HTTP requests to a server
is actually very costly--
For example, if you're in
a country that's several--
you know, further away from
the servers, where India, like--
For example,
if you were in India
and you were hitting our
servers here in San Francisco,
you might actually see
that number, like, increase,
or you might see a better
benefit from batching.
But we actually
didn't see it here.
We did manage
to improve requests.
So we dropped
two requests out.
Actually--yeah, I guess.
And we improved
the YSlow score by two points.
The biggest change
that we actually saw
was actually
the CPU time drops,
mostly because the--Apparently
the App Engine backend
had a bit of an overhead
for establishing a connection.
And maybe it's the way
that we wrote the APIs,
but doing many
operations in one loop--
as opposed to setting up a new
HTTP connection, et cetera--
will end up saving
just a little bit of CPU time.
So we actually
saved $36 a month this way.
Chris, yes, sir.
Chabot: So with all these
optimizations in place,
we're seeing
that the application
is still
making a lot of requests.
An OpenSocial application
gets requested
by the social network site
to be rendered in step one.
It will send the result back.
It then will make a request
to the social network site,
saying, "Hey, can you fetch some
information from a data server?"
It processes that, sends it back
to the social networking site,
which then gets
delivered to the gadget.
So that's six steps of
sending information to and fro
before you actually have
your fully rendered gadgets.
So how do we improve on that?
One of the really cool
new features,
one of my favorite
from the new
0.9 OpenSocial specification
is proxied content.
Proxied content is a way
for you to be able to say,
"I've got a gadget,
but the content of it
"should come directly
from my server.
I don't want to write it
in JavaScript."
And one of the big benefits
is that it requires
a lot less data
being posted around
and exchanged between
all the different parties.
So we went from six
different actions up to four.
So your server
generates all the HTML
based on the social information
that's being posted to it.
That's called
the Data-Pipelining
part of the specification.
And there's actually
a preview version of it
available on the sandboxes
from iGoogle and Orkut.
So how we should
go about using this?
Well, this would be
your gadget--XML style--
where you define, "Hey,
I've got a contents section,
"and this is the URL
where I want you
to find--to fetch
the HTML for my gadget."
And the part that you see inside
of the content section,
those are
the data-pipelining tags.
We've got a lot of documentation
on our wiki.OpenSocial site
where you can find out
what tags are available,
and how you can use them, and
in what ways they can be used
to do all kinds of
really cool tricks with them.
And then on your server
side of things
where you generate the HTML,
you would receive
the raw post, which is
basically a JSON blob
that contains
all the social information
that's being posted to your
server that you requested.
So you can decode that,
and then you can just use it
in your favorite
scripting language.
In this case,
I'm using PHP.
But you can
do this in any language
that can decode a JSON string.
So this way, you can
actually program something
in your favorite environment,
in your favorite language,
and it's gonna be really
fast and efficient as well.
When we applied this
technique to Quartermile,
we saw some really
substantial savings.
As you can see,
the gadget latency went down
from 2,700 milliseconds
to just over 1,000 milliseconds.
So it's incredibly
fast and efficient.
Even the total
page loading time went down
by quite a substantial number.
The amount of
requests we're making
went down by quite a bit--
from 26 to 20.
And the YSlow score shot up
by four points as well.
So the total monthly savings
you would be making here
is about $320
when applied to Quartermile.
So one of the problems
you're gonna run into--
one of the challenges,
I should say,
is that the social network
site will be caching
the result of the HTML
that you generated.
And it will store it
based on both
the user ID
and the application URL.
So what happens
when your data changes?
For instance, somebody posts
an activity in Quartermile.
How do you tell
the social networking site
to download
that information again
so that you can generate
the latest information
and send it to
the social networking site?
That's what the
invalidation pattern is for.
The invalidation pattern
is a new social endpoint
where you tell it,
"I've got a URL here,
"and for this user,
I want you to throw away
all the cached information
and re-fetch it from my server."
One of the things
that I wanted to note
is that a lot
of people have asked,
"So how does it know what
application this applies to?"
Well, you're using a WAF to sign
the request to the server
and a WAF consumer key
is associated
with your application.
So that's how it figures out
what its application ID is.
So how would you
go about using this?
You make a post
to invalidate your URL.
You tell it, "Hey,
I've got a JSON blob here."
And in the JSON blob,
you've got the keys
that you want to invalidate.
That's the invalidation keys.
Now these keys can be anything,
like a URL of your gadget spec.
It can be a message bundle.
It can be a user ID as well.
And when you're
posting a user ID,
you're telling it, "Flush
everything from your cache
which is related to
my application and its users."
So it will completely
clear out everything.
One of the other challenges
you're going to run into
when you're building
a social application
that you're hoping
is going to be very popular
is how to
make your database scale.
Database scaling
is really important
because when you're dealing
with social information
you're gonna end up having
tens of millions of users
if you're really lucky.
So just doing
a plain query, saying,
"Well, I want you to
match up all my friend lists,
and match it up
against activities"--
It's not going to be possible
in a normal database anymore,
'cause there's gonna be too much
information stored in it.
So one of the things
that I wanted to suggest
is that if you're actually
building the application now--
you're starting building it--
think about scaling.
Think about things like
a master/slave architecture,
where you've got one database
that you're doing your writes to
and you've got
a number of slave nodes
connected to it where you're
doing your read from.
That way you can
use a lot more servers
to make for a faster database.
And that will get you
quite a bit of runway
before you run out
of capacity.
However, at some point,
replication is not
gonna be efficient anymore
because there's gonna
be I/O contention.
There's gonna be so much
replication happening
that your servers
are gonna be spending
all their time on
replicating
and not on providing data
to your application.
So the next thing to think
about is database partitioning.
Now, database partitioning
is something that you can do
in a lot of ways.
You can say,
"I'm gonna put my user table
"in one database set, and I'm
gonna put my activities table
in another database set."
That's step one.
But after a while,
you need to partition out
those things as well
and say, "Well, everything
from user ID 0 to 1 million
"I'm gonna put
in one set of databases.
"And everything from user ID
1 million to 2 million
I'm gonna put in
another set of databases."
Et cetera, et cetera.
This should give you a lot of
runway and a lot of scalability.
And the good news is that if you
are building on an app engine,
like we did with Quartermile,
all of this will have already
been figured out for you.
And Google's provided all this
functionality
already in BigTable.
So you don't
have to worry too much
about the scalability issues.
The other thing that does apply
for App Engine users as well
is to use memcache a lot.
Cache everything that you can.
So when you're generating
something from a database
that's gonna
be used more often--
like a list of activities,
or a list of friends--
get it out of the database
and then store it
in your data cache.
That way, the next time
that you need that list,
you can just
retrieve it from memory
without having
to do an expensive query.
And that's gonna
be quite an optimization.
Another thing that
I wanted to mention is that
when you are using those kind
of caching techniques,
there might
be situations where you're,
for instance,
you're looking for a user name
starting with an "A"
in a friend list.
So what you do
is you retrieve
the entire friend list
from cache--
which is an efficient
way of storing it, there--
and then filter it
in the software
instead of actually
doing another caching set,
because then you're
gonna run out of memory,
and that's gonna be
costly in the large scale.
So software filtering
might feel unnatural
when you use the databases,
but when you're dealing
with large scale applications,
it becomes almost a necessity.
The last trick is by storing
information in JSON blobs,
and this is something
that sites like Flickr
but also applications
like iLike are doing.
When you have large lists
of pictures, of movies,
or music files, or whatever,
joining up those tables
becomes very expensive.
Then you'd be
talking about things
like row overhead
and integer matchings and--
So what you can do
is you take this playlist,
and instead of storing it
in a standard database
fashioned with IDs that
are relational to each other,
you just store adjacent blob
structure in a database
in a single entry with
the entire playlist in it.
This way, you don't have
to do your relational matching
and things are
gonna be a lot quicker.
One of the other ways of dealing
with lots of information
is background processing.
At some point,
if people have hundreds
of thousands of friends,
it's just not
gonna be efficient anymore
to go to your database
and query it for.
"Hey, did my million friends do
something in the last 24 hours?"
So instead what you could do
is use background processing.
Background processing means
you store something in a queue,
saying, "Hey,
there's been an activity."
And another process on another
server will pick that up
and slowly process through
all those activities,
creating
the end results for you.
And those end results are
actually stored
in the database
or in your caching server.
And the frontend application
just reached those results
and without
actually calculating them.
The good thing is that
this way you can prioritize it.
You can use
different servers for it.
You can say, "Well, this
is a really important activity
"that I need you to do
right now while other things
are okay to be delayed."
So this gives you
a lot of design flexibility
to make
a high volume data situation.
Another benefit is that it
doesn't block user interaction.
If we enter something
in Quartermile saying,
"I ran for two miles
yesterday,"
you don't want
the whole user interface
to freeze for ten seconds
while it's updating
all of those activity tables.
So by putting
this in the background
and putting it
in a different system,
you're not
blocking end users either.
The only downside is that users
see updates a little bit later
because you're waiting
for the whole background process
to pick it up and digest it
into its system.
So updates might
be delayed by a few minutes.
But again, that's
definitely a price worth paying
to be able to scale up
to much larger data volumes.
When you have your own server,
there's a lot of
off-the-shelf
and open source systems
that can do this for you.
You could also write
your own script very easily
inwhatever scripting language
you want to use.
If you're on App Engine,
we are gonna do
background processes soonish.
Until then, you can use
a crontab, for instance.
In App Engine you can
create a cron.yaml file
and tell it, "Well,
I want you to process
all activities
every one minute."
And that process
can check your queue,
and if there's
something to digest,
it can do its manipulation
and then store
the result in a database.
And you've got a queuing system
even on a cron-type solution.
Roomann-Kurrik:
So I'd actually would like
to bring that in
and then talk about--
when we were
designing Quartermile,
we actually had a planning
session and sat down,
and kind of thought,
"Well, how do we structure
a datastore on App Engine
for a social application?"
One of the first tenets
that we kind of came up with
for how--or like, what we
really wanted to adhere to was
to prefer to
enforce hard limits up front
than deliver
a poor user experience.
Basically saying that
if we have to limit it,
limit certain users
in order to make
everyone's experience
consistent and good.
We're willing to do that.
Also one of the first
decisions that we made
was that friend joins
were very expensive, right?
We looked at
the numbers for Orkut,
and Orkut lets you
have 1,000 friends.
Now, joining in 1,000
records may be possible.
It's more difficult on
App Engine than, say, MySQL.
But then we looked at MySpace,
and you can have
hundreds of thousands,
or you know, even
a million friends on MySpace.
So basically,
we said no, that--
we can't just arbitrarily share
data with every single person--
every single friend of a user.
Thankfully we were working
on a fitness application.
You know, we came up
with that fairly early
and said, "Do all 100,000
of my friends
really need to see that
I did ten push-ups yesterday?"
At least, do they
need to see it right away
the second that I
put it into the system?
So, uh, we said no
and decided,
"Hey, maybe there's,
like, a team of people
that you'd prefer
to work out with."
So certainly, like, drawing
from my own experiences,
sometimes there's just certain
people that you want to tell,
"Hey, I just went
out for a seven mile run."
But I don't
want to tell everyone,
not right away at least.
So we have this team system.
We basically said that
when you first use the app,
you have to either
pick a team or join a team.
And then you can invite
your friends to, you know,
have them join
your team as well.
And you saw there with
the video that I demoed earlier.
The side effect
of the team system is that
because you have to invite
someone to your team,
you're also implicitly inviting
them to use the application.
So there's actually more
growth potential here too.
So then
we started writing down
what were the goals
for performance, right?
We were using App Engine,
so we decided that we wanted
to fetch all of the team's
data for a given week
in one database query,
right?
Because there's
limits on App Engine.
You can only return
1,000 results max.
So that was a nice limit
that we had to work with.
If you were using MySQL,
maybe you would restructure it
as a goal in a different way.
Maybe you'd say the query
to get all of the team's data
for a given week has to
return a certain number of--
a certain amount
of time, for example.
So the question is, how many
users can we put on a team
knowing that
we have 1,000 results?
And it's a pretty
simple calculation, right?
We have 1,000 entries
return max.
We are storing
one workout per entry,
or one entry per workout.
And we figured
that if you're working out
three times a day,
that's about 20 updates a week--
uh, you know, 21 really.
But--and then, if you're working
out more than three times a day,
then you're probably not, like,
having enough time to do
all the social application stuff
that you're doing anyways.
So fair enough,
we know our audience.
1,000 results divided
by 20 updates a week
means you can have
50 users a team.
And when we do this query,
we can be guaranteed
that in
a single datastore fetch,
we can return all the results
that we need to show
for a single view.
Obviously not every app can have
this sort of limitation on--
imposed on itself.
So we did it hypothetically,
do the implement--
the updates from your friends.
You know, we wanted to say,
"How can we show what
our friends
have been working on?"
Certainly this
is a very slow query,
slower depending on the number
of friends that you have.
So what you basically
have to do is
is use the OpenSocial REST APIs,
fetch it from App Engine,
fetch all of the user's
friends from App Engine,
see which ones
were updated recently,
then sort the whole list
and then return
that to the end user.
Even if you're displaying only,
you know, the last ten updates,
you still have to do this
for the entire list
just to be sure that
you have the data there.
So what we did was,
again, using cron,
processed
this kind of information
in the background
of App Engine--
doing the fetch,
doing the calculation.
And then
we decided that, hey--
following Chris' advice,
we're going to store the results
of this calculation
kind of in a big blob.
But we had a few options
on where to put it.
We could've put it
in the datastore again,
and just
it would've been one fetch
to return this
whole friends calculation.
We could've
put it in memcache.
It would've been even faster.
It would've been
hosted in RAM.
But we didn't really want
the overhead of one HTTP fetch,
so we actually decided
to use OpenSocial App Data
as a place to store it.
Now, I love App Data.
I think App Data is one of the
most misunderstood and misused
portions of
the OpenSocial specification.
Certainly I have
a quote to back that up
because it's right there.
But to be...
[chuckles]
Uh, to be fair,
it's very fast.
There's no fetch from
the gadget to your application
when you're using App Data
as a store for data.
That's because it's hosted on
the container site,
and the container injects it
into the gadget
when it gets rendered.
So people misuse it
because they expect it
to work
like a normal datastore
that you'd have locally
on your own server.
It's--they want
to put secrets in there.
They want to, you know,
store passwords or credentials.
They also want to store things
like top scores
for the entire app.
And you know,
oh, I want to put
all my data that can't
be modified in there.
And to be fair, it's
not really designed for that.
It's public,
so anyone can see it.
So if you put
a password in there,
they can see
your password as well.
It's also user writeable
via JavaScript.
So even if you only code in
certain practices
into the JavaScript
of your gadget,
if you're using JavaScript
to write it
to the app--App Data
on the container,
then the end user
can modify that in Firebug
and just put in
whatever they want.
So if you're storing
something like a top score,
that's arbitrarily
changeable.
But what it's
really good for is storing
this kind of rendered
bulk data as a cache.
Because what it--it's injected
directly into the page
when the page
is first loaded,
and then you
can just call it
and dump it
into a DIV element.
So if you want to
store HTML in there,
it's a very, very quick write
to display that HTML.
There's almost
no overhead, essentially,
when you're doing that.
Um...
Talking about different
strategies and limitations,
there's certain optimizations
that will be forced upon you.
And really,
if you think about it,
there's certain things
as an app developer
that I'm sure
you'd love to do,
and the container's just
not gonna have any of it
and not gonna
let you do anything.
Certainly Quartermile
is a great example of this.
So that the Naive implementation
made a few performance mistakes.
We've already cut down
the performance by quite a bit.
The container, like
we were talking about before,
has a vested interest
in keeping
the gadgets
that it's hosting fast.
Obviously the user
sees the overall performance
of the container,
and even if a certain gadget
is slowing that down,
then the perception is
that the container is slow.
And so containers
might start influencing--
or implementing constraints
to keep users honest.
We actually
had two containers that
we ran into challenges with--
or maybe not challenges,
but just we had
to be aware of limitations.
So for example, the iGoogle--
iGoogle is soon to be
instating a latency policy
on their gadgets.
Basically that
when you have a gadget
that's running in iGoogle,
in the directory,
there will be a little marker
next to it in the directory,
saying, "This app is--might slow
down your iGoogle experience."
It makes sense, right?
Like, iGoogle wants
to be very fast.
And as a great
illustration of this,
I'm gonna show you a video
about an iGoogle page load.
You'll also see, through
the course of this video,
that there's kind of like an
implicit latency penalty anyway.
And to basically
start that off...
I hope that will play.
Okay.
So here I am
clicking over to one
of my new tabs in iGoogle.
And keep in mind--
what do you see first
when the gadgets
start loading?
Obviously there's weather,
then next there's
a Flixster app,
then there's
"The Wall Street Journal,"
and then "New York Times."
And then those last two apps
aren't even on my radar.
By now I've already picked
what I want to work with.
Maybe I want
to go see a movie.
to go check the weather.
But my attention's not focused
on the two slowest apps.
Obviously this video's
slowed down a bit.
I actually
expanded it by twice--
Well, it's about half as fast
as it would be normally.
But you can see that when
you're in a profile of context
that you're competing against
the other gadgets
that are rendering
for the end user's views,
right?
If they're
not focused on your app
and they're focused
on something else,
they're not gonna engage
with your application as much.
You're not gonna see
as much growth.
So talking about, like,
kind of these profile
or [indistinct]--
or these profile pages, or
these home page sort of views
is basically that
you have a lot of gadgets
together, smushed together.
And these are frequently some
of the most highly-trafficked
portions of the site
that they're running on.
For example, the iGoogle page
is people's home page,
you know,
for their entire browser.
So that's a huge
amount of traffic right there.
Also, for Orkut,
profiles is, like, one of
the biggest portions
of the Orkut site.
Users love putting
gadgets on their profiles.
It's kind of like
an expression,
a way to sort of
say who they are.
And so they put a lot
of different gadgets on them.
And it does affect
the overall performance
of the profile page
on Orkut.
So Orkut wound up actually
turning off profile renders
because of latency
and security issues, right?
They didn't want
dynamic code executing.
Thankfully they
turned them recently back on
with a new OpenSocial 0.9
feature called Templates.
Basically, Templates
is a way that you can declare
what data
your application needs.
And you can render it
in a declarative way as well.
So there's no--
JavaScript being executed,
even though templating looks
very similar to JavaScript.
You can display social data,
data about your friends.
You can display App Data,
so if you're using the cache,
that's a great use for it.
You can't use external fetches
or dynamic data fetches.
Here's an example of
what a profile render
in a template
might look like.
You'll see,
I'm requiring two features:
opensocial-data
and opensocial-templates.
So that's the division here.
First of all, you say
what data you need,
and then the second is--
how am I going to show it?
And you'll notice that when
I'm including the templates,
I'm adding an
extra optional parameter
called process-on-server.
And that basically says
this template should be
parsed by the server, don't
execute any of it client-side,
strip out
any JavaScript, whatever.
And that's more of
a security thing.
Somewhat of
a performance thing too,
because that rendered output
can be cached
by the container.
So the blue
little snippet at the top
is a people request for
their friends in the viewer.
And then the green at
the bottom is a repeating DIV
that repeats on each friend
and outputs their name.
You'll notice that
it's actually very similar
to the PHP sample
that Chris posted
for the
proxied content example.
So we talked about a lot
of different optimizations,
and I kind of want to bring
everything back together
and kind of give you that high
level overview one more time.
Basically we had three
different types of metrics
that we were measuring on,
and we found
different approaches
affected different one--
each one differently.
So for example, if we
wanted to reduce app size,
we used
a JavaScript minification.
Content rewriting,
use the dynamic--
or use
the static content proxy.
Data pipelining was
a great benefit for our gadget.
And then
invalidation and setting
our cache headers correctly
affected the app size--
the download size--
the bandwidth that was used.
Um, note that some of
these are in blue.
Those are the ones
that are in aggregate,
or are beneficial
over many views.
They're not--so they're not
gonna affect
the--a single app render.
And that's why we don't
have real, like, metrics,
because this is going to vary
from app to app.
The benefit can be
really huge, though, you know?
If you're caching
static content,
then you can probably see,
like, 90% reduction in traffic.
If you're
caching dynamic content,
depending on the caching
that you're doing,
you'll see less than that
but it'll still
be a significant gain.
So think
about all the numbers
that we had
in this presentation,
and you can go and
look online later, afterwards.
But adjusting caching
can have, you know,
tens of percentage points
impact on those numbers as well.
Reducing
the number of requests
was improved by JavaScript
minification, spriting,
content rewriting--
because it kind of
did those automatically
for us--
and setting our cache headers.
Again, cache
headers in aggregate,
fewer requests over time.
Finally, latency, basically
JavaScript minification,
spriting,
rewriting, proxy, batching,
optimizing the datastore--
everything we did
Actually, I'm sorry, batching
should not be in that list.
Everything but batching seemed
to have an impact on latency.
Batching probably should,
we just didn't
see it in the numbers.
Keeping that in mind, we kind
of took everything together,
and we tried to use as
many optimizations as possible.
And we
have what's considered
the most optimized
implementation.
The net gain--obviously
we saved 1.6 seconds
off of each page render
of our gadget.
From the gadget's
point of view,
we saved about 0.6 seconds from
the end user's point of view.
We saved 20 HTTP requests.
And we improved our
YSlow score by 17 points
to a respectable 89.
I'm sure we
could've pushed it more,
but these changes are already,
like, fairly significant.
We saved $325 off
of our monthly costs,
assuming that we were a
fairly heavily trafficked app.
So keeping in mind that,
you know, like,
the costs might not be
staggering,
but when you can shave,
you know, 0.6 seconds off
of your gadget's
rendering time,
what does that mean in terms
of usage and adoption
for your gadget as well?
We saw a direct correlation
on high-level sites,
like Amazon and Google, between
latency and user adoption.
So being able to
improve by this vast margin
means significant impact
for your application.
And because we're actually
running very close on time,
if there's
any quick questions--
I don't think
I set this up in time.
So I'm going to check moderator
and see if anything--
but if anyone wants to
come up and ask us questions
for the next three minutes,
that'd be great.
Chabot: So we only have
three minutes at the moment,
but we also have
the OpenSocial office hours
just down the hallway here.
So if there's anything else
that we can't cover
in the next three minutes,
that would be
a great place to look us up.
Cheers.
So anyone? Questions?
I think we're saving it
for the office hours.
Cool.
Roomann-Kurrik: Thank you.
Chabot: See you there, guys.
[applause]